march 8
2022 is that the official release date
for hogwarts legacy people of the
internet retroarch and tour here and we
have yet another hogwarts legacy leak
hit the like button if you've heard that
one before as you all know i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell and we've got some juicy juicy
leaks to discuss today now as i alluded
to in the opener this leak pertains to
the game's release date i would also say
it comes from a reliable source but
there's always a butt with these things
right i still don't personally believe
it's actually the release date for the
game in today's video i'll explain the
full leak why i think it is legitimate
but still doesn't give us an accurate
release date and i know you're probably
asking how can the leak be legit but not
have the correct date well let's dive in
this one actually all started back in
september when nvidia suffered a leak
through their cloud gaming subscription
service geforce now the leak was a
database of games but the big deal here
is that it contained a number of
unannounced titles some of which have
ended up coming true such as god of war
for the pc other games in that leak as
apparently coming to geforce now
included other sony titles like eternal
and demon souls as well as completely
unannounced games like a bioshock
remaster titanfall 3 and many others
we've since seen at least part of this
leak turn out to be true as for nvidia's
official statement at the time they
claimed the list was quote used only for
internal tracking and testing close
quote they would also go on to add that
some titles were speculative and not
confirmation nor an announcement of any
game fast forward to now and we have yet
another geforce now leak only this one
includes release dates if you take a
look at this list which i'll link to in
the description below you'll see
potential release dates for games like
crisis gears of war mortal kombat and
yes harry potter universe wait what yeah
for some reason it lists a game being
developed by avalanche software and
published by wb as harry potter universe
now before you get too excited i don't
think this is another harry potter game
i do think it's probably just a
placeholder title they used for hogwarts
legacy who knows maybe this leak is so
old that it's before we even knew the
official title and what i mean by old
leak is even though this just happened
now it very well could be old
information and that leads me back to
the release date the leak shows march 8
2022 as the release for harry potter
universe which i think we can be pretty
sure is hogwarts legacy now as i said in
the beginning i do think this leak is
legit in the sense that it probably is
actually files directly from the geforce
now servers what i don't think it means
is that this is the official release
date for hogwarts legacy first off if
it's releasing in march they would
really need to ramp up the advertising
and marketing for the game very very
soon that's right around four months
away and at this point we haven't heard
a peep about this game for more than a
year now i think the most likely answer
is that this is simply a placeholder
date maybe it was put in there by
someone at nvidia who knows they very
well could have even gotten confirmation
directly from someone at wb or avalanche
but even then it could still just be a
placeholder date until they know the
official one now there's another
interesting angle to this that i think
is going to warrant its own separate
video but yes guys i am well aware of
the toy magazine you heard me write toy
magazine which gave a very tiny update
on hogwarts legacy and it seems like it
may hint at the game releasing after
fantastic beasts 3 which we already know
has been confirmed for april 15th 2022
so if that is the case that would
certainly put another point on the side
of this whole thing with nvidia just
being a placeholder date but more on
that in the next video now maybe there
are some of you out there who don't
follow the gaming industry too closely
so you may wonder what i mean exactly by
placeholder date well this isn't a
practice that's unique to the video game
industry you actually see this with a
lot of different websites the basic idea
is retailers have to prep for the
release of new products well in advance
of the actual launch date this is so
they can have all their back-end systems
set up and ready to go and all they'll
have to change are the details such as
release date or maybe something in the
product description this makes things a
lot easier as they don't have to
scramble to get everything ready at the
last minute they can already have all
this in there pre-loaded and just make a
few tweaks as needed so that's what i
think is going on here i think this is
very likely just a placeholder date for
hogwarts legacy maybe it came from wb
maybe it came from geforce now just
taking a guess to me though the most
interesting aspect of the whole story
would be if the march date was an actual
target date for avalanche at some point
maybe they did actually give that number
to the folks at nvidia at some point in
fact many people hoped back when the
game was delayed from 2022 that maybe
because they had initially announced
2021 it was actually close to release
and they just needed more time to polish
things up as time has gone on throughout
the year of 2021 though and we've gotten
no new information that certainly led
more and more to believe this game won't
see the light of day until very late in
2022 myself included i've said for a
while now i think it's holiday 2022 but
what do you guys think will hogwarts
legacy release on march 8th 2022 let me
know in the comments below as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon